[Music]
did Wonka show you just a single word of
Pure Imagination or is there more to
come for the young Chocolatea and his
tiny orange friend here's what the
ending of Wonka really means willly
Wonka is an immigrant fresh off the boat
in a new land with Big Dreams of making
and selling chuckler inspired by his
mother but he has no money to his name
desperate for a place to stay he takes a
suspiciously cheap room deal from Mrs
scrubb and bleacher unable to read the
fine print forcing him into Decades of
indentured servitude woner plans to pay
off his debts by selling chocolate also
face a roadblock of the chocolate cartel
led by slugworth who wereing Cahoots
with the chief of police to shut down
all competition Wonka teams up with
scrubb its's other Hess victims to
surreptitiously build their chocolate
Empire though they occasionally have to
resupply ingredients stolen by an
umaluma seeking payback for a previous
cocoa theft Wonka's most significant
friend in this group is noodle an
orphaned girl who teaches him how to
read Wonka's magical Confections prove
so popular with the public that he's
eventually able to open his own store
the opening however is sabotaged by the
cartel who pay off scrubb it and
bleacher to poison the store's Supply at
his lowest point Wonker is given an
ultimatum if he leaves town all of his
friends debts will be paid off on the
boat out of town thepa lumper catches up
with Wonka encouraging him to fight back
against the cartel Wonka realizes that
slugworth signal ring matches noodles it
turns out she's slugworths niece and she
wasn't freed but instead bought by
scrubb it and bleacher to keep her out
of of her family's Fortune Wonka returns
to reunite with his friends for a
massive Heist to acquire the documented
evidence of the cartel's crimes they
find the documents but the cartel traps
Wonka a noodle in a flooding chocolate
chamber the ypa Luma still on the trail
of Wonka's Chocolate ends up rescuing
them before they drown the police turn
on their corrupt chief after seeing the
evidence the cartel leaders are blown
away after eating Wonka's levitation
candies and the chu explodes into a
fountain Wonka opens a bar of Chu he's
been saving from his mother and ins side
is a golden ticket with a message about
the joy of sharing chocolate with people
noodles's mom is found allowing for a
mother daughter reunion as Wonka sing's
Pure Imagination and Wonka and the Umpa
Lumpa make a deal to work together to
build the Chocolate Factory Wonka spells
out its ultimate moral loud and clear
literally writing it on a golden ticket
it's the old cliche of the real treasure
was the friends we made along the way
delivered with just enough conviction
and earnestness to hopefully make
viewer's eyes water more than they roll
Wonka's motivation from the beginning is
driven by his love for his mother and
though she's no longer with him except
in memory he's now built up a group of
friends and has a found family he seeks
to take care of the movie also makes
clear that you can balance caring for
others with pursuing your personal
dreams Wonka was ready to give up the
latter for the sake of the former but he
realizes he can do both what are you
doing I'm making chocolate of course
this message is perhaps the one thing
the movie has in common with the 2005
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
whereas to Burke in the 1971 movie used
w primarily as an Arbiter of sin and
virtue for the kids visiting the factory
to learn lessons from the 2005 movie
shifts the ark more towards Wonka
himself learning the value of family the
difference is that Johnny Deb's version
of Wonka learned that lesson at an older
age after having a much more fraud
relationship with his own family while
the ending of Wonka Works successfully
as a conclusion to the movie
self-contained narrative it's weird as
an origin story for this particular
character whether you're talking about
the book or the two previous movie
adaptations will he Wonka is a character
famous for his mysteriousness and
reclusiveness the Gene Wilder version in
particular has a sharp cynical Edge he
doesn't even faint caring about kids
getting injured on his factory tour and
even Charlie nearly gets screwed out of
his reward due to the fine print and a
contract he couldn't possibly read if
Wonker is all about a younger Wonka
learning the value of friendship isn't
it weird to think he'd later go on to
shut himself up in his Factory and shun
the outside world perhaps the lumpers
would be friends enough for him in his
recluse years but surely he'd want to
stay in some contact with noodle and his
other human friends as well right
furthermore it's sad to imagine this
version of woner screwed over by
contract law and his youth growing up to
be the same man who would try to do the
same to other people the suspense is
terrible he going to go this I hope
it'll laugh it's not really clear
whether this is a standalone story about
wly Wonka or intended to eventually
segue into the events of the novel and
films Paul King's film does offer some
points of Distinction that might imply
this is a different continuity where the
book explicitly takes place in England
and the 1971 movie in the United States
Wonka seems to take place in a fantasy
setting their monetary currency of
silver sovereigns is fictional magic
holds a greater presence in this world
than it did in other Wonka stories
especially in the musical numbers the
period is also distinctly indistinct
with an
anacronismo slugworth is definitely a
different take from the 1971 version in
his performance Timothy shalamay isn't
attempting an impression of Gene Wilder
if anything his exaggerated comic
deliveries and good-natured yet foolish
characterization feel like they take
more inspiration from Jim car's
performances if shalam Wonka is supposed
to in fact be a younger version of the
Wilder Wonka then presumably a lot is
going to change in his life between
Wonka and whenever he gives Charlie
Bucket a factory tour if the shalam
Wonka is to eventually become the Wilder
Wonka it would be at least in part
thanks to the influence of the hug Grant
OA Luma though he only appears for brief
portions of the film The OA lumpas turn
out to be one of its most important
characters in terms of moving the story
along his characterization is in many
ways closer to the Wonker audiences
already know and love both in his
wittiness and in his extreme pursuit of
justice that borders on sadism by Lumpa
law any crime must be met with 1,000
times of punishment the sort of
philosophy that might justify turning
annoying gum chewing kids into
blueberries or shrinking television
addicts and teleporting them into a TV
it's the Y Lumber who encourages Wonka
to fight back against the chocolate
cartel setting the story's climax in
motion while this fighting back doesn't
escalate into the nightmare fuel of book
Wonka or Wilder Wonka's ironic
punishments it does at least push the
character a bit closer to Classic R do
style Darkness rather than keeping him
purely a figure of innocent Whimsy
combine the umal Lumber's influence with
noodles starting to give Wonka a more
proper education on non-chocolate
subjects and you can at least imagine
the roots of how this version of Wonka
is starting to become closer to the
original in some ways even if the power
of friendship stuff makes him more
different in others in an interview with
Games Radar coinciding with the release
of the film's trailer in July Paul King
gave insight into how he went about
approaching his conception of a younger
Wonka doing so was a challenge he said
before continuing to say but I also felt
maybe misguidedly but just probably from
those childhood readings that I did know
who this person was how do you like it
dark white nerdy absolutely insane he
pointed to the end of Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory as proof of how
even the age cynical version of the
character still believed in goodness
kindness and hope which was key to
developing his younger version noodle he
explained was necessary as a slightly
more cynical person to counterbalance
young wona innocence even so King
acknowledged I'm not sure my soul is
quite as dark as Ral dolls that
sentiment goes some way to explaining
why the film ends on such a happy note
with Wonka's positivity genely intact H
Grant's job both in performing in and
promoting Paul King's films has been to
bring his trademark and tanker asness to
a role that could otherwise risk
becoming sickly sweet speaking to the
associated press alongside Timothy
shalam Grant took shots at the
director's perfectionism and the
strangeness of playing an NPA Lumpa
while still making it clear he loved
being part of the production talking
about the film's moral he said it's not
a trit tacton motto it comes from his
heart charam seconded this assessment
that the director really means it while
acknowledging he'd be suspicious if he
heard about it from the outside charam
compared the experience to his work on
Greta gog's Little Women in terms of
being an adaptation of a classic story
that's done well enough to overcome skep
iism about IP based movies this movie
was like a breath of fresh air with a
story that's outside the bounds of R
doll's original material I thought it
was magical in a total film article King
revealed he was open to making sequels
to Wonka he pointed out how Ral d a
writer who didn't really write sequels
nonetheless kept exploring different
things he could do with the character of
willly Wonka he wrote Charlie and the
Great Glass Elevator featuring Wonka And
even had plans to write a third book in
the series so there's plenty of
potential for continuation King said
there's an awful lot more Wonka story
that we have that we would like to tell
it's not like Dune part one where you go
this is what's happening in part two
hopefully it works exquisitly as a
standalone movie but I would definitely
like to do more and I'd like to spend
more time in this world and meet some
more OA
lumpers